Okay.
There is a lot to this next story and I want
to make sure I get to everything.
So the big picture is that a bunch of senators
have been caught selling huge amounts of shares
of stock after getting a briefing about Corona
virus.
But while publicly they and Donald Trump continued
to claim everything's fine, we're prepared.
This is no big deal.
Now, these are mostly Republicans.
There is a claim that Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein also did the same.
But when I look at the details, it doesn't
look like Dianne Feinstein is actually part
of this crony crew.
So let's start going through it.
First of all, reports that Republican Senator
Richard Burr sold somewhere between 600000
and $1.7 million in stock after getting a
bunch of briefings about how Corona virus
was coming.
But while publicly Burr was still think saying
things like the U.S. today is better prepared
than ever before to face emerging public health
threats like Corona virus, privately, he was
dumping stock presumably in advance of the
crash that ultimately came.
And of course, that stock market crash did
eventually happen.
The Corona virus briefings included one on
January 24th, also attended by Senators Kelly
Laughner, Republican Ron Johnson, Republican
James Inhofe, Republican Dianne Feinstein,
Democrat.
That gets us to James Inhofe.
James Inhofe sold a whole bunch of stock in
pay, pal Intuit, which makes TurboTax, Dana
Corporation, Brookfield Asset Management and
Apple of Tim Apple fame, of course.
Kelly Loffler tweeted about being at that
briefing on January 24th.
She said, quote, Appreciate today's briefing
from the president's top health officials
on the novel coronavirus outbreak.
These men and women are working around the
clock to keep our country safe and healthy.
She then started selling stock, but also buying
stock in companies that would do well during
an area during a time of quarantining and
work from home.
For example, buying shares of Citrix, which
runs sharing service ShareFile and Remote
Access Service logged me in.
The fifteen's stocks that LOFFLER reported
selling have lost more than a third of their
value on average since she reported selling
them.
We don't know the full scope of her portfolio
changes and holdings.
There's definitely an incomplete picture there.
She later claimed that all of these decisions
to buy and sell weren't made by her.
She said on Twitter, quote, This is a ridiculous
and baseless attack.
I do not make investment decisions for my
portfolio.
Investment decisions are made by multiple
third party advisers without my or my husband's
knowledge or involvement.
That's her assertion.
Then we get to Ron Johnson and Diane Feinstein.
Now, both of these situations seem different.
Ron Johnson's thing seems different in that.
On March 2nd, that was well into this crisis.
He sold a stake in his brother's company.
That's a privately held company.
The Ron Johnson thing seems like a different
thing so far.
And then there's Dianne Feinstein, the Democrat.
Her husband sold biotech stock Allergan at
a very low price.
It actually went up after they sold it.
Then coming back down.
Currently trading slightly below where it
was when when they sold it.
Maybe Dianne Feinstein told her husband what
was going on.
And they said even though the stock is at
an all time low at that point, let's sell
it anyway.
I don't know.
It's far less obvious that Dianne Feinstein
was doing the same thing.
Now, it's really important to understand that
a lot of people are debating is this actually
insider trading?
This does this actually represent trading
on inside knowledge about a particular company?
But the thing that you have to remember is
that members of Congress have a different
set of rules.
They have to stick to it's called the Stock
Act.
Stock is an acronym.
It's the stop trading on Congressional Knowledge
Act.
Obama signed it into law and it prohibits
the use of any information that's not public
for private profit.
This includes insider trading by members of
Congress and other other government employees.
It has a whole bunch of sections which we
don't.
There's no sense in going through each section.
But the point of the STOCK Act is specifically
to deal with situations, not about a particular
company.
So you could argue it's not really insider
trading.
It's not.
I found out Apple is about to have this issue.
It's not public knowledge.
I'm dumping my Apple stock.
The normal sense of insider trading may not
apply, but the Stock Act certainly does, where
knowledge about a national security.
Issue or a pandemic or whatever, you are not
allowed to trade on that information for private
profit.
Insider trading, it can be debate debated.
This is clearly a violation of the Stock Act
by every indication, at least for Richard
Burr and Loffler.
I got a ton of messages saying you have a
David.
What are the consequences going to be?
I think you all probably know the most likely
outcome, which is nothing.
Nothing's going to happen.
We don't have an administration nor a Justice
Department that has any appetite to go after
stuff like this right now.
Really, really ugly stuff.
And I hope that I'm wrong about that.
There has been a shareholder lawsuit filed
against Richard Burr.
You know, from what I'm reading, legal analysis,
it's not likely to go very far, but this is
another way in which know we talk about two
justice systems.
We talk about two tiered a two tiered economy,
probably more than two tiers.
This is another way in which the people in
charge, the elites, have a completely different
world in which they live.
And not only do they live in a different world,
that world is increasingly isolated from the
consequences that people outside that world
would typically have to deal with if they
did the same thing.
This is another example of that.
And what is increasingly clear as we'll talk
about this later and tomorrow, Donald Trump
looks like he's ready to say no more distancing.
Let it rip.
Old people stay home.
Otherwise go crazy, which is extremely dangerous.
Other than that, we are we are increasingly
seeing that Corona virus may be very profitable
for a lot of people.
And in many different ways, government slush
fund contracts potentially going to be available
soon to a lot of corporations.
Insiders from the government making moves
in terms of stocks to not necessarily always
make money, but avoid the losses that many
of us have suffered to our portfolios, et
cetera, so that the two tiered system never
more clear than now.
Quick reminder.
I hope that you are staying home.
One of the things we've done is we've rescheduled
The David Pakman Show of your chess tournament
to tomorrow night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, March,
25 Wednesday, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
I'll be straight.
I'll be playing in it and streaming my games.
Anybody can play regardless of skill level.
I will tweet out the link at about 7:45 p.m.
Eastern Wednesday night.
You can use that link to play.
We'll be playing on leech test dot org.
So just grab a subscribe, make an account.
It's totally free.
Make an account on Legistorm again.
And I hope you will join us tomorrow night
for the David Pakman Show Viewer Chess Tournament.
In the meantime, let me know what you think
about the Stock Act violation allegations.
I'm on Twitter at The David Pakman Show David
Pakman.
Dot com.